so we'll open him up he's just just set
up an exercise a drill okay so this hand
goes inside
inside his knee
don't open your armpits
learn not to open your armpit so go high
guard i mount on you oh this is much
worse
so
inside
this way palm facing
pawn to palm
nothing weird
inside
bottom hand
here
where his pelvis is
not where there's hinges
his stomach pushes in
his ribs can flex
where there's no hinge
on his pelvis
okay
so it's got to be
deep
and once you add strikes
you don't want to be on that shoulder
line do you see his power line right
there
you're going to be deep
in anyways
okay
so
inside note
on the palm note and then deep
into him
here
push up
that makes no sense to do bridge and
then
come back down and try to turn
so you have to use the in space behind
you that you create in the bridge so
in tight
boom
turn in the in space and that's what
opens your hands
this hands where it goes
right in
out
reset the drill
palm to palm
in his knee
deep
under him
boom
bridge turn to split your hands
when you're switching roles
start out administratively
just a shape for him to work
but in the middle as he goes
i'll lower my center
and then
i'll
reset
the position
more dynamically
you gotta do it all at once
there you go
so not like that
reset
low
contact base
okay there's a noggin nuclear roll okay
boom turn
split your hands on the turn
everything's at once
good the longer you hold that bridge the
stronger you have to be
that's better
then try to get your head off the
striking line even those even though
there's no strikes you should train like
there is
you got to get deep
your head is still on that striking
[Music]
you guys stay low
okay it's gotta happen at once
palm the palm not not there you go
okay you're on your head's on his
striking line
turn more before you come down that much
keep going
good a little lower ronin once you come
back to admin
split your hands to the knee and hip
there you go
feet near your butt feet near your butt
the further your feet are from your butt
the weaker your
bridge is
right now they're pretty far
better
lower ronin right
split your hands when you turn split
your hands
good come back low ronin you're too high
when you come back you'll come back low
and then you'll go up into admin
split your hands there you go all the
trains better
he wants to punch me
his maximum power
is when he gets his weight into it
that's not up there
he puts his weight
do you see and he's gonna
have that cant in his torso
the same one you use in all your
nagewasa
okay
so look where it is
drive dude like you want to knock me out
there you go you see that difference
stay there
look at the cat
in his body
you're doing an angle of
deflection
and an angle of deviation
[Music]
like you always do
so
here's his line of attack
there's my angle of deviation
then my angle of reflection
he throws a strike
boom
same thing
angle of deflection
my head movement
angle deviation
so i'm not just throwing him
over while i keep my head here so he
goes to strike
i'm not just doing that because you'll
still get tagged
is his weight
on the fist line no it's a little ahead
we'll go slower so you can see
it's a little ahead
so i have to get my head
not here where it's comfortable my head
has to go
in the opposite direction
of the angle of deflection so he goes
i can't stay here because he's gonna get
just enough so go back where you feel
there that's where his power line is but
i had it going a little forward
so i have to go
in of that line he goes to punch
and i'm back here
when this happens okay this is not
comfortable for me
this is comfortable
but you know what's more uncomfortable
that
okay
so
we go
and i go in in
[Music]
okay
as the
get off of that line
okay
you have to go in you can't leave your
head and shoulders here
do it
elbow knee okay so
um everything still applies
i'm in here
boom
out
okay
uh
here
this is already
your open guard get your knee to that
hip
so
boom
and then start to turn
to get your hands
back in the fight
here's the fight
this is not the fight
this is the grappling match
he's still trying to punch me
get your hands
back in the fight
and they move with your body
and when you move
that will allow you
to begin another shrimp
that gets the bottom leg
once it's out
grab
look at my hands
open up
you see
here
no different get out
move out
no different
okay
we're there
there are my hands
he's gonna want to do what what were you
doing yeah he's trying to smash me do
you see he's trying to keep weight on
so i'm going to help him not want to do
that
okay
anchor that was your guard that's all
you did different
and when you shrimp out for the bottom
leg
that blade of your forearm
goes into his trachea area so he's gonna
try to smash
and he he will find that uncomfortable
and i will find that
mechanically sufficient
okay so i have a 45 in my arm
and my
elbow
upper arm is what's keeping them off
so we're here he's trying to smash me i
just need to hold that long enough
to come underneath
because this arm's occupied
this arm goes underneath
checks
i shrimp out
same thing
get your knee in first
okay
so from this position
you have a knee here
and i have a knee here
you're in open guard
okay
again
shrimp again
to get the leg out the bottom
okay again
inside
striking line
hands back up
knee immediately
in front of his hip
don't try to get this foot out from here
yet
the fight is still here he can still
drop punches on me
go ahead
he can still drop punches
get your hands up
and deviate
again look
here
away from the other punch
check
knee up
put that foot down to help bridge if
your abs can't do it
then attack his
phone
and now you're in the closed car
a lot of this has to do with uk
if buki is not continually pressing
there's no need for the second shrimp
okay
so ooga has to do their job
start out admin
but he has to pay attention to the
striking line
here i am you see
low trying to climb on there he got it
okay then i'm gonna try to punch him
why don't you go into the angle
deviation instead go back
angle deviation instead there it is
okay boom
attack the arm
good
all right you got it
okay
uh
your deflection is in your angular
deviation your deviations in your angle
deflection don't stop to block
move from covered positions okay move
with your angle of flexion okay